I want to say this to guys and I excuse
me for saying it but and I feel really
bad saying it but up until yesterday I
swear to God I didn't know what read it
was that's like not possible you heard
about it's not I've heard about it
but I didn't know what it was I thought
it was a legal Oh
I said no elements of like if I go on it
right that the FBI you know and the CIA
is gonna know my email underground [ __ ]
yeah you just need facebook for that
yeah but then I you know explored a
little bit and I and I there's this
thing division morbid reality I clicked
on that and then they have umbrellas
under that that's a tunnel and then
people dying yeah and then I saw the
first video I saw was this young kid 14
maybe slicing a guy's head off I was
alive it was crazy in hi dad yeah just
with the knives you know and I don't
really she says I can get PTSD from that
I don't think that you have to feel a
certain way while you watch it but it
does creep into your sub-conscience and
I don't think that it is healthy for you
to I have a little more depressed I'm
yeah yeah really up but he has this
thing he has a fascination for tragedy
porn
he loves looking at like kids you know
that image of the of that young boy in
Syria covered in that suit and all that
so sad like he loves that stuff and
there's a sexual way to do why'd you put
porn kids that is a real sickness in
America people love to feel bad and they
go through this yeah like what do you
know they do nothing here but the Korean
ferry okay so there was Korean ferry
rides about right and there was these
high school kids they were doing a field
trip to an island off of Korea and it
sank everyone died mostly kids mostly
kids and CNN had this video of a father
Korean father seeing the body of his son
right and you can't see his face you see
the white tent and what you also see is
like police officers are around the tent
protecting it and you can hear the
father
born in grief right and all the police
officers are crying right and I I
watched that probably a thousand times
they cry
I like crying you know the story about
that that that one of the teacher you
know like the the teachers were at fault
for that because they told all the kids
to stay I know
but yeah and one of the teachers that
survived hung himself
oh yeah tree so you didn't know about
that yeah I didn't yeah when you said
Korean ferry I thought you were talking
more like a serial killer called the
curries oh my god yeah I mean and also
the captain of the ship right is in
prison for life yeah because he abandon
ship abandon ship now if you're a
captain just any captain's listening
right now okay look at me right now if
you're a captain of a [ __ ] fairy or a
cruise liner or anything of that sort
and the [ __ ] ship sinking I better
find your body on that [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] passengers you should be the
last [ __ ] in there okay you
don't abandon ship that's bad it's bad I
feel like you would be a captain who
would abandon ship there's no way you
would sick [ __ ] [ __ ] like this what
she says she'd like this is that really
makes me [ __ ] angry yes power there
is no element of that how about you
here's the second [ __ ] thing now
power couple at work shut the [ __ ] up
the [ __ ] up Gilbert okay stop laughing
runner you run when [ __ ] gets bad you're
not a relationship stay or even in
relationships if something remotely goes
bad you want to just run the other
direction you don't want to fix things
you're not a true captain of the ship I
just want to say this okay that let me
ask you something am i a captain of a
ship
well you always say you're the cat I
know I know I know yeah in JIT this is
because it's a metaphor right but in
Maya captain of a real ship I'm asking a
question
no no why because you wouldn't know how
to steer a boat in the right
I know because I can learn all that
stuff why because when [ __ ] went down
I'd be the first one to leave the
[ __ ] bottle that's why I'm not one
I'm saying so I'm responsible enough to
know that there's no there's no way I
can be a captain of a ship because I
will leave that [ __ ] and you'll
be eaten by a shark
okay am I in the military no because I
will run I will not fight these are
things that I've made choices early on
on in my life I look at my life I look
at myself in the mirror and I know what
my character defects are okay I'm a
coward I'm a [ __ ] I don't fight yeah
all right but there are I have assets to
that I do and every human being should
look at other faults under the
weaknesses and their pros and cons and
go this is what I should do okay so
that's what you're saying but what I
you're saying right now is blasphemy
[Music]